- We're back, we're in Tokyo,
we're Worth It Japan part dwa.
- Is dwa a two in any language?
- It's French.
- Un, deaux, trois.
- (laughing) wait, what.
- You combined two and three.
You know how you know we're in Tokyo?
The Tokyo Tower and the sound of cicadas.
(loud growl)
You hear that?
- We had to bring along
our friend, translator,
tasty producer, lovely person
all around, Rie McClenny.
- Hi.
- We're gonna be eating
things that come on rice.
- [Rie] In a shell.
- We may even put on some fancy clothing,
which we've never done
for a restaurant before.
We're doin sushi.
- Well, let's go, how do you say let's go?
- (speaking foreign language)
- [Group] (speaking in foreign language)
- Today on Worth It, we're gonna be
trying three excellent sushi places
at three drastically
different price points
to find out which one is the
most worth it at its price.
- [Steven] And we made the mistake
of coming in 95 degree heat.
- Worth it.
- I'm super excited, the
first place we're going to
is an highly automated sushi
restaurant called Kura Sushi.
- We call it Kaiten-zushi,
kaiten is like spin.
- Sushi is brought out to
you on a conveyor belt.
- I wish I could be conveyor belted
to this restaurant right now.
- You want me to try?
- Yeah, conveyor belt me.
- Alright.
(grunt)
- [Rie] Bye.
- [Steven] I fought Yoshi.
(laughing)
(upbeat percussion music)
- (speaking in foreign language)
- For somebody who's never been
to a conveyor belt sushi before,
can you explain how it works?
- (speaking in foreign language)
- What are the advantages to having
the automated systems in the restaurant?
- (speaking in foreign language)
- Wow.
- Whoa.
(laughing)
- [Steven] So excited, each
of these plates is 100 yen.
- Approximately one US dollar.
Then we have self service green tea here.
- [Steven] Woo!
- [Andrew] Never seen someone
so excited for hot water.
- Hot running water.
- Yeah at your table.
- Come on, sometimes my
shower doesn't even do that.
- Kanpai.
- Hot!
This is the optimal time,
it's like enough time
for you to look at it,
decide if you want it,
but then it's like if you don't get it,
you're not gonna get it.
- It's like the Tinder of dining.
- Yes, swipe,
right.
- Swipe right.
Alright, here we have two
beautiful shrimp coming by,
come on Steven.
- Okay,
maybe we should just go for it.
Pop it open, pop it.
- [Andrew] First hit, here we go.
- [Steven] Oh yeah.
- Here Steven,
- [Andrew and Steven]
(speaking in foreign language)
- Perfect!
- Oh, now I'm excited, now I'm gonna grab,
hey how about some tuna.
- [Steven] Tuna!
- [Andrew] I love tuna.
- [Steven] Look at this long cut of tuna.
Cheers it up, that's so great!
- [Andrew] Yeah, we can
have as many as we want,
they just keep coming.
- Ahh!
- Ever been in a lazy river?
- Yes, oh my God.
- This is the lazy river of food,
instead of you in the river,
the food is in the river,
you just seize the river.
- [Rie] Sanma, it's a pike mackerel.
- [Steven] Mm, the fish was tender,
the rice was well
packed, like satisfactory
in all of the ways that you
want sushi to be, what is this?
- [Rie] If you get five plates.
- [Andrew] You get to play the game.
- [Andrew and Steven] Oh no!
- [Andrew] What happened?
- [Rie] You lost.
- [Andrew and Steven] Aww.
- So if we won, what would happen.
- You get the toy in a plastic ball.
- And then I want dessert, next.
Oh, fluffy ice with green tea red bean.
- [Andrew] Nice, the order was heard,
thank you.
- Was heard.
(gasp)
- [Andrew] Oh here it is.
- [Steven] Cheers!
- Mm, that's what you need
when it's hot outside.
- (whistled blow) Ice blast.
We're at eight plate count.
- [Andrew and Steven] Nine.
- [Andrew] I'll just do it.
- I touched it.
- Okay, we're at the baseball stadium,
I like it.
- Come on.
Yeah, get home.
Oh, we won!
- Did we really?
- [Rie] Yeah.
- [Andrew] No way, it's coming out.
(excited laughing)
Got some stickers.
- So I thank you for the meal.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Andrew and Steven]
- That was wonderful.
- Fun and cheap.
- Yeah and very technologically advanced,
which I appreciate.
- So, we're headed to our next sushi spot,
but before we do that, we
asked Rie for a suggestion
on any desserts that
would look fish shaped.
- [Rie] We're here.
- [Steven] Here we are, here we are.
I love it, it's a beautiful stand.
- [Rie] Konnichiwa.
We are eating taiyaki,
it's a fish shape pancake.
What do you want?
- [Steven] I want a red bean taiyaki.
- [Rie] Okay.
- [Steven] Andy wants matcha.
You can have the matcha one Andy.
Aw, it's so cute, I got the red bean.
- [Rie] It's a green tea.
- Alright, we're gonna
try this taiyaki now.
I also have red bean.
- Alright.
- Look, fish, cheers.
- [Andrew and Rie] Cheers.
- [Group] Mm.
- [Steven] (speaking in foreign language)
In the 1980s, Norway had too much salmon.
And so there was a guy who was tasked
by the Norwegian government
to sell some of it to Japan.
He was able to strike a deal
with a company called Nishi Ren
and that catapulted salmon
into the sushi market in Japan.
- We didn't have salmon sushi before that.
- That is a great international collab,
to bring a new all star
food into prominence.
- [Rie] When you eat fish shape food,
do you eat from the head or but?
- [Steven] Head.
- [Rie] Head.
- Where we goin next Andrew?
- So next we're on our way to a place,
called Shun sushi, is that right?
- I'm here.
And it comes recommended by one
of our colleagues named Hitomi actually.
- Yep, my work wife.
- Your work wife?
- [Rie] Yeah so this restaurant
is neighborhood sushi joint.
Somewhere you wanna go once in a while
when you are craving sushi,
sushi chef knows you.
- Oh, that's what I want.
- Yeah.
- I want my sushi chef to know me.
How do you get a work wife?
- You have a work wife.
- [Steven] Who?
(laughing)
(upbeat piano music)
- (speaking in foreign language)
- I'm curious how long you've
worked as a sushi chef.
- (speaking in foreign language)
- Today we're gonna be
ordering the omakase set.
- Hai.
- What is the choice of fish
that you're gonna be serving us.
- [Chef] (speaking in foreign language)
- Yes, absolutely.
- Yes.
- So what do we have coming first Rie?
- [Andrew] Sake.
- [Group] Kanpai.
- Do we shot this, or, no we just, okay.
(laughing)
- [Andrew] Ooh, he's grating wasabi.
- You know what I love about sushi?
You're seeing everything that goes into
what your money is going to.
- [Rie] So this is chutoro.
- Here we go, first bite.
- [Andrew and Steven]
(speaking in foreign language)
- Pure and utter joy.
- You know it's not like a piece of fish
on top of some rice.
It tastes like a single unit.
- Yeah.
- [Chef] (speaking in foreign language)
- (speaking in foreign language)
- That was delicious.
- Mm, so happy.
- Very pleasant texture,
it's also really interesting,
the temperature that it arrives.
Sushi, I don't think, is a cold food.
It becomes a part of your mouth instantly.
- (speaking in foreign language)
- The best temp, is body temp.
- [Chef] (speaking in foreign language)
- It's unbelievably sweet.
- Yeah, it's kinda light.
- What did you do to the uni?
- (speaking in foreign language)
- It tastes like melon.
- [Chef] (speaking in foreign language)
- Mm, the squid was, ex-squid-zit.
- In a word, it was, Squidward.
(laughing)
- What do you think is
the special elements
about a sushi dinner like
this, like us sitting here?
- [Chef] (speaking in foreign language)
- So is it mini shrimp?
- [Rie] Yeah.
- [Andrew and Steven] Wow!
- [Steven] All raw.
Mm, oh my God.
- [Rie] Saltwater eel called anago.
- Yeah, Annie's face just perked up,
it comes out and she's like.
- [Andrew] Wow, look at it.
- (speaking in foreign language)
- Hey yo, it was almost like
biting into a crepe cake.
- Yes.
- I saved it for Annie, tamagoyaki.
We really appreciate
it, thank you very much.
- Shun sushi.
- It ended too shun.
(sarcastic laughing)
- I love it, it was very comfortable.
Chef was very friendly, and
I loved the conversation.
- I realize today, I want a sushi chef
like I want a hair stylist.
My hair stylist is the person I see
probably more regularly than
everybody else in my life.
I want that for a sushi chef.
- Yeah.
- This is my sushi dance, I've decided.
- [Rie] What partied sushi.
- We're going to our final sushi spot,
a place called Kyubey, and
from what I understand,
we need to get a little bit fancy.
Rie, what's goin on here?
- It's rimi shransta sushi,
everyone knows Kyubey.
The chef from Shun knows, my
dads know, it's very famous.
- Alright, let's go get that Kyubey.
- Oh, the reason we're
dressed up is because
we're eating in a restaurant
with a dress code.
I cannot believe that we got such
a prestigious sushi restaurant in Tokyo.
- Let's do it.
(upbeat orchestral music)
- (speaking in foreign language)
- Everybody we've talked to in
Japan says Kyubey is amazing.
Why do you think Kyubey
is so popular here?
- (speaking in foreign language)
- I mean, this has gotta be one of the,
I don't even know how
to talk, let's just eat.
- One of the greatest opportunities
we've had on this show.
- Yes, I'm a little nervous.
- (speaking in foreign language)
- [Andrew] Wow.
- Big inhale.
No, no, no, more, more, more.
Don't afraid, and this
is a top tool to grind.
This is shark skin.
- Oh, wow.
- Wow.
- Please touch it here.
- [Andrew] Real shark skin?
Arigatou, Gozaimasu.
- [Chef] Just one hand
is okay, too polite.
(laughing)
- I'll be less polite.
- [Group] Kanpai.
- (speaking in foreign language)
- Mm, it's gonna be a good night.
- [Chef] (speaking in foreign language)
- [Rie] So this is tai snapper.
- [Andrew] Why does he
tap it with the knife?
- [Chef] (speaking in foreign language)
Feel?
- Yeah
- Here, no?
- No, sorry.
- I'll make wasabi double than them.
- [Steven] You're not
strong enough Andrew.
- I'm scared.
- [Chef] Don't feel?
- Mm, I feel it now, very good, yeah.
- (speaking in foreign language)
- [Andrew] Oh wow, there's
green onion underneath them.
So excited.
- [Steven] What is this fish?
- [Chef] This is turbot.
- [Andrew] Oh, turbot?
- And touch top the sushi,
this side, bottom and fish.
Softly, softly, and you have.
- It was really amazing.
- Yeah, the springiness of it.
- You try the next way to
pick up with the finger.
- Okay.
- Thumb and center finger.
- [Steven] Are you gonna eat that?
- [Rie] He keeps those live shrimp
in a same temperature as the sea water.
Slightly warm rice with cold shrimp.
- [Chef] (speaking in foreign language)
- [Steven] Finger.
- [Rie] (speaking in foreign language)
So he's gonna give Annie a cooked shrimp.
- Already seasoned.
- Uuuuni.
- [Chef] (speaking in foreign language)
- Are you kidding me?
- [Andrew] Your father
invented this style?
- [Chef] Yes.
- They make this in Ohio.
- Please go while the seaweed is dry,
I want to hear the
crispy noise of seaweed.
- That is incredible tasting.
- That was everything,
cold, uni, the wasabi burn,
the warm rice, the crunchy
seaweed, everything.
- I would have thought that,
that was like hundreds of years old.
- That style called Gunkan-maki,
Gunkan is a battleship.
- Oh, Gunkan-maki.
- I love that.
- Battleships.
- Cause they kinda look like battleships.
- That's my favorite.
- We should get some more sake.
- No, would you like some Adam?
Adam's a sucker for good glasses.
Adam took a sip of the sake and said,
I just realized how all sake
was supposed to taste for the first time.
- Yeah.
- [Chef] Head of shrimp.
- [Rie] I think he wanna
utilize all the ingredients,
the real head to tail.
(laughing)
- It's like a little shrimp chip.
- [Rie] (speaking in foreign language)
- Mm, wow, wow.
- Oh, oh, mm.
- [Chef] (speaking in foreign language)
- [Steven] It's so beautiful.
- Oh wow, that was really
new tasting for me,
because I've had a lot of sardines before
but never like this baby taste.
- Yeah I was expecting
more of a fishier taste.
- [Chef] (speaking in foreign language)
- [Andrew and Steven] Mm.
- Wow, it's so custardy, it's like flan.
- Wow.
- And then Adam died.
- [Chef] (speaking in foreign language)
- [Group] Aw.
- [Rie] What a hospitality.
- Usually when I put on my suit
I have to go somewhere I'm thinking
what is this night gonna
bring me but havin a great.
(gasping)
(laughing)
- [Rie] Abalone.
- Wow.
- Havin a great time.
Feel like I'm hangin out
in somebody's basement
just playing video games.
- I feel like I've stepped in
something I can never go back.
- The thing that was, every piece had
its own kick about it,
or it's own character.
- It's own personality.
- Yeah.
- (speaking in foreign language)
- [Rie] This is it.
- Have a question?
- I do, I have one question?
Why is sushi so great?
- (speaking in foreign language)
- Well thank you very much.
- Thank you so much.
- (speaking in foreign language)
- We are glad you enjoyed.
- [Andrew] It was so good.
- Thank you very much.
- I'll never forget it.
- Guys I wanna say,
ya'll look snazzy today.
Adam especially.
- You don't look too bad yourself there.
- Thank you very much.
Doesn't change the fact
that we have to do our jobs.
And our job today is
which sushi restaurant
was the most worth it to you at its price?
- I truly loved every place we went to,
although at first glance a lot
of the preparations might look the same,
you really got a
completely different thing
at every restaurant.
And I think each would be worth
going to at their price point.
For me, if I came back to Tokyo,
I would go to Kyubey,
I think it's that good,
it would be worth the price every time.
- Rie?
- I liked this episode a lot,
sushi's something special in Japan
and you can enjoy different level.
My Worth It winner is Kyubey.
- [Steven] Oh, I knew it.
It's also not too expensive.
- You can spend a lot
more at a restaurant.
- I wanted Shun to be my winner
because it was like my barber of sushi.
But I do also have to go Kyubey.
He paid attention to every detail, Annie?
- Kura sushi.
- Wow, Adam?
- [Adam] I liked Kyubey.
- [Steven] Kyubey,
Kyubey.
- Wow.
- That's it for sushi,
quick shout out to Daiki,
all this way from Taisai, Japan,
who helped us get into Kyubey.
We're still in Japan, we
got one more episode here.
- It's Rie's favorite food.
And we're visiting a special old friend
next week on Worth It.
- [Andrew] He noticed you
were left handed right away.
Have you ever felt so noticed?
- [Steven] No, I didn't feel noticed
when I went into seventh grade
and all the chairs were built
for right handed people.
So, he's better than chair
manufacturers, that's for sure.
- [Steven] Oh, yes!